let's go
Leben am Limit bis zum letzten Tropfen
hier jetzt backe salams
[Musik]
heute gibt es ein geniales klassisches
Tiramisu auch ohne Ei ein Zitronen
Tiramisu und am Ende noch ein
himbeer-tiramisu jetzt kommt der Sommer
ich freue mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
der Sommer kommt die Erdbeerzeit kommt
und im Sommer essen wir alle ganz gerne
Desserts ein klassisches Dessert ist ein
Tiramisu und da werde ich immer wieder
danach gefragt Sally mach doch mal ein
klassisches Tiramisu auch ohne Ei das
ganz ganz klassische Tiramisu Rezept
gibt es schon auf meinem Kanal das ist
so das Original mit Eigelb im Sommer
will man ja aber auch mal ein Tiramisu
Rezept was man draußen stehen lassen
kann und deswegen gerne auch mal ohne Ei
vor allem möchte ja nicht jeder immer
rohes Ei verzehren das heißt dieses
Rezept ist so das Grundrezept daraus
könnt ihr das klassisch Tiramisu ohne Ei
machen dann werden wir noch eine
Abwandlung machen mit Lemon Curd also
ein Zitronen Tiramisu und am Ende noch
ein Himbeer Tiramisu und davon gibt's
auch ganz wieder Abwandlung also wir
können das Thema Tiramisu auch wirklich
ins Unendliche spielen und wirklich jede
mögliche Variation machen falls euch das
klassische das Zitrone oder Himbeer
Tiramisu nicht anspricht schreibt mir
gerne in die Kommentare welche Version
ihr noch sehen möchtet ob es tatsächlich
Schokolade ob also da fallen mir einfach
schon direkt ganz meine Sachen ein jetzt
aber erstmal zur zum Basisrezept für die
Creme nehme ich 750 Gramm Mascarpone 400
Gramm Schmand 150 g Puderzucker
Vanilleextrakt 20g Amaretto Amaretto
gibt es übrigens mit und ohne Alkohol
ihr nehmt das was ihr gerne mögt und 500
Gramm Schlagsahne in nehmt jetzt zuerst
den Mascarpone der Frischkäse ich muss
mich immer dran gewöhnen das heißt der
Mascarpone ich sage immer die aber ist
egal Mascarpone einfach in die
Rührschüssel geben und schon mal ein
bisschen verrühren dann Schmand
Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt dazu und
wenn ihr mögt und ein klassisches
Tiramisu macht gerne mit Amaretto
arbeiten mit oder ohne Alkohol und
später dann die Sahne dazu gießen und
alles schön steif schlagen
[Musik]
so sieht die Creme jetzt aus ihr dürft
jetzt nicht zu lange schlagen damit die
Mascarpone und die Sahne nicht gewinnen
ich habe auch extra kein
sahnestandmittel dabei denn Tiramisu ist
halt schön cremig und ist eher nicht so
standfest wie es eine Sahnetorte zum
Beispiel ihr könnt das ganze auch
cremiger gestalten denn bei einem
klassischen Tiramisu ist ja so das
Eigelb dabei ist mit Mascarpone ohne
Sahne und es ist eher cremig und es
luftig und locker wenn ihr sagt euch das
so zu locker dann reduziert ihr die
Sahne und erhöht den Mascarpone Anteil
wenn ihr aber sagt so ist es genau
richtig dann probiert es gerne aus so
ist es halt auch nicht so schwer im
Magen ne dann ist halt so ein bisschen
locker und leichter ich stelle es jetzt
aber mal so kurz in den Kühlschrank und
zeige euch noch die Zutaten die wir zum
Füllen benötigen
für das klassische Tiramisu nehme ich
jetzt hier ein paar Löffelbiskuits habe
hier etwas Kaffee und auch Amaretto und
auch hier da gibt es die alkoholische
und die alkoholfreie Variante könnte
dann gerne einfach miteinander
vermischen und den Kaffee habe ich jetzt
auch schon abkühlen lassen wer gar
keinen Kaffee mag kann stattdessen zum
Beispiel auch Milch nehmen oder etwas
Kakao oder auch gerne einen Saft das
geht auch alles wunderbar und ein
Tiramisu könnte jetzt entweder in der
großen
Schale Auflaufform würde ich jetzt mal
sagen Schichten oder ihr könnt auch
einzelne Gläser machen deshalb Gläser
weggläser die ihr dann eben einzeln
portionieren könnt also da entscheidet
ihr einfach wie es machen wollt ich gebe
das jetzt hier mal
in eine tiefe Schale
und dann nimmt er einfach eure Löffels
und sie kurz vorsichtig von beiden
Seiten und schichtet das ganze hier rein
[Musik]
ganz schön glatt streichen und jetzt die
zweite löffelschicht drauf noch eine
Creme drauf und fertig
[Musik]
und ich finde das sieht schön aus wenn
es ein bisschen wellig verstrichen wird
jetzt kommt es leider der schwierigste
Part nämlich der Kühlschrank Part ihr
stellt das Tiramisu nämlich abgedeckt
für mindestens vier Stunden kalt aber
die Zwischenzeit überbrücken war mit
Lemon Curd und Himbeer Tiramisu
für das Zitronen Tiramisu habe ich jetzt
hier bereits einen Lemon Curd
hergestellt das Rezept findet ihr auf
meinem Blog und ich habe es auch schon
als Shops geteilt und zum trinken nehmen
die einfach etwas Orangensaft ihr könnt
Mangosaft nehmen ihr könnt Leben und
Cello nehmen alles was ihr mögt ich
nehme dann noch die Löffelbiskuit dazu
und die Creme die ich auch eben
zubereitet habe allerdings ohne Zugabe
von Amaretto hier mache ich das Tiramisu
einfach um euch zu zeigen ihr könnt in
verschiedenen Formen Schichten entweder
Auflaufform oder ihr nimmt z.B auch
einfach einen tortenrahmen ein
Backrahmen könnt dann nämlich hergehen
und die Löffel Biskuit im Orangensaft
trinken
ich habe den jetzt hier sogar selbst
ausgepresst
dann da drauf
[Musik]
die erste Schicht ist drin denn
Backrahmen habe ich jetzt drumherum
jetzt kommt hier das Lemon Curd dazu
[Musik]
jetzt noch Schicht Creme oben drauf und
ihr entscheidet im Prinzip selbst wie
hoch das Tiramisu sein soll oder wenn
ihr sagt er hat eine größere Form können
das natürlich auch ein bisschen flacher
stapeln ganz wie ihr mögt
[Musik]
ich finde es immer schön wenn es nicht
ganz glatt ist und zur Dekoration gebe
ich einfach bisschen Lemon Curd noch
drauf so als Klecks verteilt ist ein
bisschen ein paar Zitronenscheiben ihr
könnt auch gerne noch Kokos drauf
streuen
Raffaello Kugeln
[Musik]
da muss ich sagen ich hätte auch einfach
eine riesen Schüssel packen können weil
gibt mir eine Schüssel voll Zitrone
Tiramisu und ich behalte einfach für
mich
das könnte ich jetzt so komplett
aufpassen aber es kommt erst den
Kühlschrank und es kommt noch Variante 3
für die dritte Variante habe ich jetzt
auch noch mal Creme angesetzt und das
wird jetzt die Himbeer Tiramisu Variante
dafür nehme ich jetzt heute keine
Löffelbiskuits sondern Amarettini Kekse
die schmecken nämlich auch richtig gut
ich habe hier Himbeeren die werden
gleich püriert da könnt ihr gefroren
oder frische nehmen etwas Puderzucker
Tonka und noch mal Himbeeren zum
Dekorieren und gefriert man im
Augenblick dazu okay hier machen wir so
Himbeeren Puderzucker und Tonka einfach
kurz pürieren
okay hier ist wirklich so leben Armen
Limit bis zum letzten Tropfen hier
[Musik]
und die Schicht die ich jetzt hier schön
portionsgerecht in diese kleinen
Förmchen
also erst einmal Kekse
könnte auch ein bisschen stampfen nicht
aber nicht
dann einfach mit Himbeerpüree und
Mascarpone Creme
da fehlt noch mehr oder ja
und dann einfach mit Himbeerpüree und
Mascarponecreme fertigstellen
[Musik]
drauf
und die Gefriere
richtig süß oder die kommen jetzt auch
in den Kühlschrank und dann probieren
wir alle drei Tiramisu Sorten ich freue
mich schon drauf
[Musik]
alle drei Tiramisu Rezepte sind jetzt
zubereitet hier beim klassischen
tiramisu-feld ist nur noch Kakao dann
nehmt ihr bitte Backkakao und am besten
so ein kleines so ein Sieb und damit
nicht zu viel Kakao drauf landet nehme
ich immer Kakao mit Reis also nimmt
einfach trockenen Reis der kommt hier in
Sieb rein und ich habe einfach immer so
ein Schälchen mit trockenem Reis und
Kakao weil ich dann immer wieder
benutzen kann und den Reis eben nicht
entsorgen muss und der Reis hindert
quasi den Kakao dran zu sehr und zu
schnell aus dem sie zu fallen also ihr
könnt die Menge des Kakaos besser
dosieren
[Musik]
wir probieren Tiramisu Nummer eins ohne
Ei ohne Alkohol okay
magst du eigentlich Tiramisu gut Kinder
können ja oft Tiramisu nicht mitessen
wenn es eben ganz klassisch ist mit ein
und Alkohol also deswegen ist hier alles
ohne du machst eigentlich wenn du so
machst immer ohne Alkohol und so aber Ei
finde ich nicht so schlimm also ich
finde ich habe nichts gegen rohe Eier
[Musik]
1 2
cremig aber luftig
[Musik]
okay auf dieses Tiramisu freue ich mich
schon richtig ich habe es jetzt schon
aus der Form gelöst und geschnitten ich
habe es auch halb angeeist ich habe es
nämlich ins Gefrierfach gestellt und so
ein bisschen anfrieren lassen damit man
ein halb geeistetes zitronentiramisu hat
Tolga
herzlich willkommen hallo
probieren einfach Geistes
zitronentiramaten
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich glaube das ist mein Favorit oh mein
Gott das
ist richtig gut
es ist eine Weltneuheit das gab es jetzt
bis jetzt noch nie
so ähnliches in meinem Buch
aber so ein Geistes aber Geist gibt's
nicht
das ist hammer boah ich will eigentlich
jetzt das Video beenden okay
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Favorit mal gucken
aber das ist halt mit Amaretti
diesen so richtig wie geschmolzen ist
also es geht so
lecker
ich kann es nicht sagen also ich finde
klassisch lecker Zitrone geeist lecker
Himbeere auch alle drei lecker ich bleib
bei Zitrone aber ich bleibe glaube
richtig gut probiert gerne
in die Kommentare welches Rezept davon
ihr ausprobieren wollt klassisch oder
Himbeere oder ob euch noch eine Version
fehlt
tatsächlich
Kombinationsmöglichkeiten Mango Kokos
oder sowas
game in dem Tiramisu Game gibt es kein
Ende also probiert es aus schreibt uns
in Favoriten und wir sehen uns wieder
bald beim nächsten Mal tschüss
und jetzt kommen so demnächst so Erdbeer
Spargel Rhabarber Grillen jetzt kommt
der Sommer ich freue mich jetzt richtig
lecker aber jetzt
kann ich aber das geht schon
[Musik]